i'm happy to join dr hinshaw to provide
our weekly update on covet 19 in alberta
the data we're sharing today is from
tuesday may the 3rd to monday may the
9th
i'm pleased to report that we continue
to see signs of declining viral
transmission across the province
our average pcr test positivity rate is
about 23
a month ago we were around 27
compared to the peak in early january
we're almost down by half
this downward trend indicates that
transmission is slowing
virus levels in our waste water are also
trending down almost at every site
that includes calgary and area
which has been near the previous peak
level but is now turned down
and most important of all
i'm pleased to report that
hospitalizations decreased over the past
week including patients in icu with
coven
it's sterile early days
all these numbers fluctuate from day to
day and they won't necessarily drop in a
straight line from here
but it looks like the peak in
hospitalizations was april 26 around two
weeks ago and the
experience
and with the experience in quebec and
ontario where we're seeing the numbers
in hospital turned down over the past
two to three weeks following the same
turn in wastewater and in case data
this is good news for albertans
and for our hospitals and our health
system overall
assuming it continues it will mean fewer
admissions
fewer beds blocked and fewer staff off
sick because of covet
now emissions may not continue to drop
straight down every day but we hope to
see relief soon for the staff and
physicians in our hospitals
covet itself is adding less to the
numbers in hospital right now than we've
seen in the past ways
but the system is under real strain
nonetheless as i've noted before
hospital occupancy is high
in edmonton and in calgary in particular
and a few of the largest sites are
operating at over 100 capacity
there have been peak levels on and off
recently right across the province but
the pressure is concentrated in the two
big cities in line with our usual trends
overall occupancy in the five smaller
regional sites in may to date is well
within levels at this time of year uh in
past years before the pandemic
in ems and emergency in particular we're
seeing very high numbers of patients and
pressure on response times as a result
as i said before this wave of demand on
the system will pass
but we can't just wait for that to
happen the system needs more capacity so
that it's not strained so much at peak
times regardless of covid
we're supporting ahs and adding staff
right across the system including in key
areas and i'm looking forward to giving
an update on this in the coming days
as to why we're seeing such heavy volume
right now there's no one single cause
for it the realities
is that volumes and emergency vary
widely from one month to another month
and year over year
we're seeing a cyclical peak right now
like some of the higher seasonal peaks
we've seen in past years and like we're
seeing in other provinces
part of it is late season influenza and
other infections circulating more as
people get back to normal
and when i speak to clinicians
and conversations that i've had over the
past week they say another big part of
it is a rebound in demand because people
deferred so much routine care especially
early on in the pandemic volumes and
primary care dropped shortly at that
point in time including a drop as much
as a quarter in emergency visits
our health care providers have worked
hard
to be available and encourage patients
to come in and the system has mostly
recovered in terms of access to that
routine care like cancer screening for
example
but covet 19 is going to keep impacting
the system
right across the country for some time
even as the current wave of the virus
recedes
for those still at higher risk we
continue to look for any new tool that
can help and that includes looking
closely at how we make the best use of
pax logan
to date over two thousand prescriptions
have been provided and our supply sits
at nearly thirty thousand a pack slovid
is not the right choice for everyone
its use is based on expert judgment of
the balance of benefits and risks for
different groups of patients
our experts have looked at alberta's
data
which shows an increase in
hospitalization risk for older albertans
with certain conditions regardless of
their vaccination status
those conditions include diabetes
obesity chronic kidney disease
congestive heart failure copd and
moderate to severe asthma
based on this review i'm pleased to
announce that we're expanding
eligibility for pexlovit
starting today it will include people
aged 60 and over and first nations
people age 50 and over with two or fewer
doses of cova-19 vaccine and at least
one pre-existing condition and
people age 70 and over and first nations
people age 60 and over with three or
fewer doses of vaccine and two or more
pre-existing conditions
now that's in addition to the people who
are currently eligible
that's immune compromised albertans and
all those living in continuing care
regardless of their vaccine vaccination
status
now i i understand this is this is
complex but the details can be found
online at ahs dot ca backslash covid opt
again that's ahs.call
opt
a reminder that time is of the essence
when using paxlovid so if you have a
positive cova-19 test and believe you
may be eligible for the drug please
contact your primary care provider or
ahs for more information
and of course while paxlovit is an
important option vaccination continues
to be the best way to protect ourselves
and others around you this includes
getting every dose we're currently
eligible for including boosters that's
why last week we launched an awareness
campaign to remind albertans 12 years of
age and older to get their third doses
the theme of this campaign is it's time
to get your third dose and its sole
objective is to have more albertans
boost their protection
against severe outcomes of coven
we're investing in this campaign to help
create prevent as many people as
possible from facing serious illness
hospitalization and death from the virus
and we know that the one best way to do
that is to get more albertans to choose
to get vaccinated
i've heard some questions about the
uptake of fourth doses since we've
expanded eligibility last month and i
want to provide an update on our
progress so far
as of may 9th more than 120 000 eligible
albertans have received their fourth
dose
eligibility includes all individuals 70
and older
first nations inuit and metis people age
65 and older and all seniors in
congregate care
but remember that these individuals need
to wait five months from their third
dose that's an important point because
not everyone in the target groups are
currently eligible for some it may still
be a month or longer before they're
eligible for their fourth dose
that ensures that albertans are getting
the optimal protection available from
each dose
and as more albertans reach their
five-month milestone in the coming weeks
we expect fourth doses to continue to
rise accordingly
but we're not just waiting for that to
happen alberta health is working with
our partners to ensure that as many
eligible albertans as possible receive a
fourth dose with a focus on operators of
congregate care sites where seniors live
over the last month public health teams
across the province have been working
closely with continuing care operators
to ensure they have the support they
need for their residents to get a fourth
dose
ahs will continue to work with them
until all sites have been able to offer
residents uh the coven 19 vaccine and
we'll continue to monitor and take
further action as needed so once again i
would like to give special thanks to all
of our healthcare workers for doing such
a tremendous job in getting us through
this ba2 wave and with that i'd like to
now invite dr hinshaw to give her update
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
before i get to our covered numbers i
would like to provide an update on two
other public health matters
first i'd like to provide an update on
severe acute hepatitis in children
particularly as this week a number of
possible cases were announced in ontario
alberta has been working closely with
federal provincial and territorial
partners to monitor emerging information
we've also been working to align our
reporting criteria with other provinces
and territories in this case the current
world health organization and public
health agency of canada definitions
this will allow us to consistently
report case information to the federal
government and help contribute to the
global body of work to understand more
about this condition
late last week alberta shared
information with clinicians on this
province on what to look for and how to
report acute severe hepatitis of unknown
cause in children
we're currently in the early days of
working to gather information and there
have been two possible cases reported to
us in alberta youth under the age of 16.
due to patient confidentiality will not
be providing identifying details
however i can report that one individual
has been treated discharged from
hospital and is doing well
and one remains in hospital undergoing
treatment
it is important to remember that the
definition for possible cases is very
broad which means that any child with
severe liver inflammation for whom a
cause is not found is being counted
there are many causes of hepatitis and
it can take time to investigate to
determine if there is a known cause
this means that a case may initially
present in one of these possible unknown
cause categories but after further
investigation or testing a diagnosis may
be determined
if that happens the case would be
removed from the possible case count i'd
like to make it clear to parents that
this reporting does not necessarily mean
that there is an elevated risk in the
community or that you should take
different steps if your children are
sick
if you have concerns about your child
for any reason as you typically would
please seek care for them
if there is an infectious cause of these
hepatitis cases precautions like regular
hand washing and staying away from
anyone who is ill will be helpful
these precautions are also important to
take for other reasons like the late
season rise in influenza cases
unfortunately
i'm sad to report that there have been
three deaths due to influenza this year
my sympathies are with those who have
lost a loved one
severe outcomes from influenza and other
infections are always possible
especially for those with risk factors
like older age or other health issues
the timing of the influenza season is
later than normal likely because the
protective measures that were in place
for covid throughout the winter were
extremely effective in stopping the
spread of influenza
as influenza infections are now rising
simple actions such as keeping our hands
clean
and staying home when feeling unwell
continue to be important in protecting
ourselves and others from many
contagious illnesses
turning to today's covet update
between tuesday may 2nd and monday may
9th our pcr test positivity rate ranged
from 16.8 percent to 26.1 percent with
an average of 20.7 percent for the week
as the minister mentioned the number of
people in hospital with covet 19
decreased from the previous week
currently there are
1225 people in hospital with covid19
including 37 in the icu
sadly between may 3rd and may 9th 70
deaths related to covet 19 were reported
to alberta health with an average of 10
per day
my condolences go to the loved ones of
these albertans and to anyone who has
lost someone they cared about no matter
the cause
these severe outcomes show us that this
virus continues to pose a significant
risk to many in our province
especially those who have not yet been
been vaccinated or have not received all
the doses they're eligible for
more than one vaccine dose is required
for many diseases to build and maintain
strong immunity as protection can wear
off over time
other viruses may change or mutate over
time making the original vaccine against
them less effective
that's why booster shots or additional
doses are strongly recommended for
various vaccines
this is true for the covid19 vaccine and
others such as influenza tetanus and
pertussis also known as whooping cough
the evidence is clear for those diseases
and covid19 that more than one dose is
required to maintain a high level of
protection over time
this is especially true for older
albertans
the data shows us that in the last four
months
albertans between the ages of 60 and 79
with no vaccine
were more than 17 times more likely to
be admitted to hospital with coverage
than those with three doses of vaccine
and those in this age group with no
vaccine were around 25 times more likely
to be admitted to the icu with covet in
the last four months compared to those
who had three doses
these numbers make a compelling case for
getting every dose you're eligible for
to avoid the worst outcomes this disease
can bring
as long as it's been five months since
your second dose of vaccine and you're
12 years old or older
you can receive your third dose today
and as minister kopping mentioned we
strongly recommend those who are
eligible to receive a fourth dose or
make arrangements to get one as soon as
five months have passed since your third
no matter what dose you're receiving
vaccines continue to be available across
the province by appointment or on a
walk-in basis
this not only helps you to reduce your
risk of getting seriously ill but also
reduces the impact on our health care
system when as many people as possible
enhance their protection
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thanks dr hinshaw uh no one here in the
uh on site in edmonton but i think we've
got a couple of reporters on the line so
we'll take the first caller please
thank you matt woodman ctv
hi there my first question is from
minister copping uh minister we continue
to hear from albertans who are concerned
that your change the insulin pump
therapy program will cost their families
thousands of dollars and many people are
asking for the august deadline to be
pushed back my question is is your
department listening to those albertans
and do you have any plans to push the
deadline back as they've asked
no thanks so much for the question you
know as you as we talked about before
now this is part of our overall approach
in terms of renewing our support for
people with diabetes and the program you
know phase one we increase coverage for
uh you know diabetes strips and other
supplies uh phase two was for juvenile
continuous uh glucose monitoring and
phase three is and this is the latest
phase um which is how do we move into so
we can you know new pumps uh and people
can't be get you know uh avail
themselves of the new pumps that are
coming out and also transforming uh from
a uh a program run by alberta health to
uh to one that is actually under under
the blue cross there's roughly 4 000 so
we are working
the reason we made the announcement so
we can advise people that we are
changing and we did get input from the
the program's chemical advisory
committee on on insulin pumps in terms
of moving forward in the spaces because
we'd heard that people want to have
access to new to new pumps but we need
to make sure
that we can do this on a financially
sustainable basis so you know we've
heard some concerns we are in the
process of uh
and this is why we announced it early so
we can reach out to individuals and
there's there's time enough to be able
to get them transferred over to the
uh over to the new program uh you know
we understand that you know the
majority of individuals uh are either on
an existing program right now or have
coverage uh in another in another
program uh so we're gonna work through
that and then for those who don't have
coverage to get them transferred over
that um and there's you know uh there's
costs associated some costs associated
with that but also for low income uh
there are supports to that through our
virtual healthcare health blue cross
plan
thanks minister matt do you have a
follow-up
i do a different issue you mentioned
that hospitalizations are decreasing
ones related to colvid but we're still
seeing an average of 10 deaths per day
over the past week or so so aside from
encouraging albertans to get vaccinated
is there more this government can do to
save the lives of albertans
yeah so we are continuing a vaccine is
the uh the single uh biggest tool in our
arsenal to be able to protect against
severe outcomes so we continue to uh uh
urge people to get vaccinated that's why
we we started another campaign to get
uh to get uh third doses uh and again
ask all individuals to uh um to be
mindful of you know uh you know what
environments that that they are in as
you know especially with during the um
throughout this wave we we continue to
to have uh protective measures
particularly in areas where there's uh
where there's concern and the most
vulnerable uh so again continuing care
issue continuing care sites in hospitals
and we're working with continuing care
sites on on fourth doses so you know
that is our our focus again my heart
goes out to all families uh and friends
who have lost loved ones due to cover 19
and we continue to you know
you know even though we're the wave is
the ba2 wave is coming down uh it's
still circulating out there so we
continue to urge everyone uh who haven't
you know who hasn't got their shot or
hasn't got their booster to please do so
because that's the best protection uh
that they can provide for themselves
thanks minister uh we'll take two more
calls so operator we'll go to the next
one please
thank you madman smith edmonton journal
hi there my question is for the minister
um minister kopping you mentioned that
there are hospitals that are
over 100 capacity in uh
calgary and edmonton are you able to
give a breakdown of what
numbers of those people that are causing
it to be over capacity are from covid
and what are other reasons of people
needing uh care at this point in time
yeah i can't give an ex exact breakdown
we have to you know uh and maybe i can
ask uh press secretary steve buick to be
able to give a uh give a more detailed
breakdown in terms of when we talk about
over 100 capacity that's you know i was
referring primarily to uh you know
emergency departments and there's some
inpatient awards that are there as well
uh in certain hospitals i i did have an
opportunity last week to
visit the royal alex in edmonton they're
the red deer regional in uh in red deer
and in the foothills hospital and have a
conversation with with uh
you know doctors and and it's being
driven by a number of things so covet is
one of them that number is coming down
um which is you know thankfully for that
so that is but there's also infl
influenza um we're having a late season
spike so that's driving it another issue
is driving it's you know and it depends
like the royal alex for example um the
opioid crisis is is driving that and
then higher levels of acuity uh and this
goes to
uh you know earlier on in the pandemic
there were you know fewer people went to
see their primary care docs um and uh
and then their conditions actually got
worse which now they need to see an
emergency department to be able to
address that or get or get inpatient um
inpatient service so it's a combination
of all these factors it's slightly
different from depending on what
hospital you go to uh the good news is
is that one of these factors coveted
we're going to start seeing a uh
you know we're seeing a decrease it's
starting to come now uh and we'll see
that over the cutting up over weeks but
the you know you know the conversation
i've had with the doctors is and they're
doing a variety of things to be able to
uh ensure that they can provide the
service to albertans you know this
includes you know
asking people to work to work overtime
this includes
having you know certain uh
inpatient areas which and how to handle
a different type of patient uh so they
can move the res moving the resources
around
as well but the big answer and to
address this is building more capacity
within our system and that takes time as
indicated we'll announce some of our
progress uh in the coming days on that
but we are investing in our system to
build capacity and quite frankly that's
across the system so you know ems uh in
our acute care uh in hospital uh but we
know we know we need to build that uh so
our system can better respond not only
to this peak but it and then what's
happening in covet uh but whatever um
that you know we whatever crises we may
need to respond to in the future because
we need to quite frankly you know uh
stop asking our people to make high
dives and and and do over time to deal
with with with these uh these spikes
these spikes are normal
it's it's particularly acute right now
giving covid but these bikes happen over
time um but we need to be able to make
it less of a a burden on our staff might
in the way we the best way to do that is
build capacity
thanks minister uh madeline follow up
yeah uh mr a few weeks ago you had
mentioned that there was going to be a
campaign rolling out to encourage
albertans to uh get their third dose or
fourth dose covet vaccine
um can you give an update on where
you're at with that and when we can
expect to see more information on that
it's it's happening right now so
so there's a social media campaign uh
we've also sent out uh uh direct direct
mail to individuals to say hey this is
you know it's time to get your uh to get
your booster uh so uh you can
see you can see it online and we can
also send some of the materials to you
as well
right thanks for that
so we'll take one last caller please
thank you catherine grockowski alberta
today
both uh thanks minister you had
mentioned
that we need to stop
making people work overtime
you mentioned the strain on ems and
today
hsaa president mike parker
had given three suggestions for for the
ems workforce including
hiring casual employees to full time
um
[Music]
not forcing overtime
is there any
desire to take take
the hsaa up on those suggestions to
address the strain on ems
well i think uh
mr parker for his suggestions you know
we we recognize that there is a
challenge uh with with ems and the the
call volume has increased significantly
we can track it since uh uh since last
summer uh to address you know this in
part we um you know ahs uh announced a
10-point plan and actually i was pleased
you know yesterday they just launched a
uh
integrated operating center
for dispatch uh
undergo on top of dispatch and here in
calgary they have an ioc in edmonton to
be to be able to do better load leveling
and and be able to move patients through
the system and send it to different area
hospitals and uh uh urgent care centers
uh so that you know that was one part of
the the ten point plan uh in addition
you know budget 2022 we're committing an
additional 64 million dollars
to ems across the province which
includes you know in calgary and
edmonton additional resources right to
to reduce the the need to actually call
upon um
our frontline workers to to to do over
time to be able to uh deal with the
surge and then lastly uh we also
appointed a uh advisory committee to
deal with ems which uh which includes mr
parker and part of this advisory
committee has a bunch of subtables so
they're looking at ways that they can
you know improve you know rules around
dispatch to keep
ambulances in their home territory
longer how do we address the issues of
wait times that ambulance i have at the
hospitals which have been challenging
particularly right now given the huge
volumes that are coming in um that we're
seeing we're seeing that grow
but looking at different ways we can
approach that and then one one of those
tables is also looking at
the
recruitment and ret retention and
training of of of ems
recognizing that you know
this is a stressful job how do we
actually uh make it less stressful um
you know looking at work fatigue so
there's another initiative part of that
looking at work for work fatigue i'm
really looking forward to the committee
uh in which mr parker is a member to
making recommendations to me i've asked
them to make you know if there's any
quick recommendations that that we can
make that the committee agrees with that
say hey this can actually make a
difference real time um and not reduce
uh this safety then then let's try them
out so i i expect to see those uh like
in the very within uh very short order
like within the next week uh
additionally there will be an interim
report that's coming the next few weeks
um on that and then and then a longer
term report in the fall so i i fully
appreciate those issues here i thank mr
parker for the suggestion um and as a
member of the committee to be able to
work with committee members to say you
know what can we do right now to uh to
address this that we think will all work
and then let's try to
sorry minister it sounds like your mike
went dead at least here in edmonton i
think we only missed the last few
seconds so we'll go on if that's okay
with you
i catherine i i think we owe you a
follow-up but just before that uh aside
uh some of the specific questions are
really for ahs as the employer they can
explain uh you know the impact of the
collective agreement and what they're
doing uh with staffing i'll get ahs to
follow up with you separately so thanks
and catherine uh now your follow-up
yeah um we're seeing in i think this is
the second straight week we're seeing an
average of 10 people a day dying from
covet
are we expecting this
to be
the new normal is this what living with
covert looks like 10 people dying a day
yeah maybe i'll ask dr hinshaw if she
can weigh in on that i don't know if
that is just a uh what we're seeing you
know this over the last couple of weeks
or is that that potentially going to
move down but dr hinchok can you weigh
in on that
sure what we've seen in previous waves
is that the first
indicators that start to decline are the
leading indicators that are looking at
cases so from what we're currently
monitoring waste water positivity trends
typically are the first thing to fall
followed by hospitalization numbers
that typically starts to decline next
and deaths usually is the one of the
latest indicators both to rise and then
to fall so i would not expect us to see
this high level of deaths continue
i would expect that this is that
final
late indicator showing the impact of the
ba2 surge and that as we're seeing some
of those other indicators start to turn
downwards that we would expect to see
the same thing in our number of deaths
having said that
as i mentioned earlier it's important to
know that
kovidge will remain with us in
kind of
various ways we should expect that it
will return potentially in the fall with
other respiratory viruses
and
these deaths are a reminder that it is a
very serious disease for many people and
the importance of having the
all doses of vaccine that people are
eligible for to make sure that people
have as many layers of protection as
possible against those severe outcomes
thanks dr hinshaw i will wrap there so
thanks to dr inshaw and the minister and
we'll see you again next week